so what I believe you were trying to say
what can we say except Thank You Maui
you're welcome ever since you joined the
ranks of Disney characters cosplayers
have been going to the next level
you're one muscular demigod with some
wild tattoos it's not easy to bring you
to the real world but the cosplay world
has sure tried and some have even
succeeded characters like you keep the
cosplay world going strong did not see
that coming some Disney characters are
easy to cosplay but others are nearly
impossible we have found 10 of the most
epic Disney cosplays ever keep watching
to see the best Maui costumes we've ever
seen you know now is a hero to all you
doing great Gabby Gabby the Toy Story
franchise always gives us the best
villains they're kind of adorable but
totally evil and Toy Story 4 is no
exception
Gabby Gabby is the wicked doll that runs
the antique shop if you didn't have a
fear of dolls before you probably do now
this fan attended the 2019 San Diego
Comic Con and her Gabby Gabby costume is
on point she really looks like the doll
but the best part is her kidnapping
victim for key the detail is amazing
Simba Simba just can't wait to be king
but we just can't wait to see more Lion
King cosplay Simba and the gang are
increasing in popularity with the
release of the new Lion King movie
animals are hard to cosplay but with the
right wig and makeup and experienced
cosplayer can even bring a lion to life
striker cone is a professional cosplayer
take a look at his Simba it's hard to
tell if it's even a human behind that
mane the Mad Hatter it doesn't matter
whether you're talking about the
animated Alice in Wonderland or the
live-action one the Mad Hatter is one of
the craziest Disney characters ever why
you're always too small Johnny Depp
brought the Mad Hatter to light in a
whole new way and he has one of the most
impressive costumes ever but that didn't
scare gel Belle cosplay away she brought
the Mad Hatter to life in an awesome way
just like the character she was able to
think outside the box we're super
impressed with the detail in her costume
and makeup Woody Toy Story characters
are really popular to cosplay these days
but it's hard to look like a toy when
you're a person woody definitely looks
like a toy but that didn't scare this
Instagram cosplayer at all
Davi Levy pulled off her what do you
cosplay really well
she had the costumes down but the makeup
job really makes her look like a toy
brought to life
we almost expect her to yell that
there's a snake in her boo
what a great cosplay Milan and hey hey
just like Moana asks about the ocean
sometimes cosplayers ask how far they'll
go
and for this p.m. she decides to take
mallanna to the next level with a
life-sized hey hey Dana who also goes by
the name good red herring debuted her
Moana cosplay a blurred Kon in Arlington
Virginia she looks just like the
princess but the best part is her friend
dressed as hey the world's dumbest
rooster we totally cracked up when we
saw this cosplay loving the Moana theme
keep watching for the most epic Maui
costume ever Groot cosplaying animals
and toys is hard but do you know what's
even more difficult cause playing a tree
alien since Disney bought out the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Groot is now a Disney
character playing a giant walking
talking tree might sound impossible but
it's not for this French cosplayer
Johnny of jkp cosplay has made an epic
Groot costume he goes to various events
and he even has friends dressed up as
the rest of the guardians we cannot
believe that there is actually a person
underneath this costume we're so
impressed Jeanne
sure anyone can beat themselves blue and
call themselves Jeanne
but Paralympian Josh Sundquist has the
best Genie cosplay ever Josh only has
one leg but he still competes in sports
he decided to use his disability to take
an Aladdin inspired cosplay to the next
level he was able to create an illusion
of the genie coming out of his lamp
we've never seen a genie cosplay quite
like this one
one thing that we love about cosplay is
that it is truly a hobby for everyone
the Beast it's a tale as old as time
lots of people have caused played the
beast from Beauty and the bees
but it's usually done with a simple mask
not this cosplayer creative guy 5 to 7
how's the most ethic these cosplay ever
he was really inspired by the new
live-action beast he puts actual fur on
his face if we saw this guy out in
public we would think he was the real
deal do you think he keeps an enchanted
Rose at home Emperor Kuzco The Emperor's
New Groove is a classic Disney movie
Emperor Kuzco spends most of the movie
as a llama but his human form is hard to
cosplay he has a detailed outfit and his
face has a really unique animated look
oh yeah but Johanna who has the
Instagram handle of Earl Koz was able to
pull off the cartoonish Emperor she made
all her own accessories the crown really
looks like something an Incan Emperor
would wear Maui the demigod from Moana
has quickly become a fan favorite he's
arrogant and hilarious I'm going to love
you and he becomes a really good guy at
the end it's no wonder he's so popular
with cosplayers but Maui is not an easy
character to pull off his tattoos are
super detailed that's in stop this
cosplayer who was spotted at the 2019
San Diego Comic Con he asked the magical
fish hook and the tattoos are completely
accurate that must have taken forever to
put together which cosplay was your
favorite let us know in the comments
thanks for watching give this video a
big thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe we'll catch you next time on
the things
[Music]